life has come to a standstill inside
ainal Helwig lebanon's largest camp for
Palestinian refugees
it's been nearly a week of sporadic and
often Fierce confrontations between
rival factions
tens of thousands of people victims of a
decades-old power struggle have little
hope after several failed attempts to
bring about peace
we appeal to all the Palestinian leaders
in the camp without any exception we can
no longer handle this situation we are a
people who are already displaced to
begin with where should we go
dozens of homes and shops have been
damaged in an area that had little
infrastructure to begin with no formal
ceasefire is in place after the latest
round of violence prompted by the
assassination of a senior security
commander of the mainstream fatah
movement on Sunday
but one official Colonel munir makdah
tells us there is a decision not to
resolve the situation militarily
there is no decision for military
Showdown because the neighborhoods where
the armed groups are based are part of
the city of sidon we are working to
enforce a ceasefire and waiting for the
investigative committee to name The
Killers who should be brought to Justice
and other groups believed to be behind
the assassination have not confirmed if
they will comply with a truce
with so much uncertainty people are
afraid to leave their homes
how are we supposed to live our shops
are closed how can we buy food if we
don't work this is a disaster we are
destroyed
denied access to Lebanese government
services Palestinians here depend on the
U.N relief and works agency but it
hasn't been able to enter the camp
violence persists the repercussions will
spread Beyond Beyond and its residents
the city of sidon will be affected
already gunfire and Rockets have injured
civilians in nearby neighborhoods
a military option would be costly and
that's why some people fear the
stalemate might become the status quo as
life in the camp reverts to what it was
one of lawlessness and insecurity
on the outskirts of einel Helwig
Southern Lebanon